we have this one from old Rose Swig he
says exclusive I've obtained a cease and
desist demand letter sent to the project
Veritas board of directors by a law firm
representing a large group of
significant PV donors this is crazy they
say our firm represents a large group of
significant donors to project Veritas
who have grave concerns about the board
of directors reported action to remove
founder and CEO James Oakey from his
leadership position change the structure
of project Veritas entities and their
boards raising the risks for the
entity's charitable status and operate
Veritas for purposes other than those
for which the organization was
established by taking or threatening to
take these actions the board is straying
from its roots and the express purpose
for which it raised considerable funds
from the public including our clients it
goes on to say Let's uh well look at
this one they've got um
the background what happened with James
O'Keefe Virginia charitable solicitation
and Trust law the board risks violating
Virginia charitable solicitation and
Trust law and then conclusion
we understand the board will be meeting
tomorrow and that at least a at present
may be intending to take further steps
toward reducing Mr O'Keefe's leadership
role and Authority resulting in
redirection of the mission of project
Veritas we ask that the board
immediately cease and desist from taking
such steps as they risk violating
Virginia charitable solicitation and
Trust law as well as the governing
documents of the project Veritas
entities we also asked the board
immediately cease using vertas funds
which were solicited using Mr O'Keefe
and his reputation for purposes of
carrying out the organization's mission
in any manner contrary to that mission
board actions including official actions
and unofficial disclosures which damage
mroki's reputation have the further
effect of negatively impacting the
execution of vertas's Mission please
also consider this letter as a request
to preserve all tangible evidence
whether held by the board or by its
members personally including all
documents related to the subject matter
of this letter I'll put it simply for
you guys people donated to Veritas
because they believe in James O'Keefe to
remove him is to basically take them
money and use it for a different purpose
yeah I think that they they hit on a
really important point that there would
be an actual shift in uh the work that
that Veritas does without without James
there I mean he is the the face the
heart and soul of of project Veritas I
understand they have other people
working there and stuff but I mean I
don't think that without without James
O'Keefe I don't think they're going to
have the impact especially yeah go ahead
no you go I was just going to say I
think it's going to backfire and
everyone I mean I've only seen support
for James O'Keefe and I know him
personally and I know he's like willing
to die for this to expose the truth and
I just think it's really disgusting to
see these backstabbers and like I'm
friend well I was friends with one of
the Ring leaders alleged ring leaders
and I don't consider him a friend at all
anymore I think it's super shady and
it's really sad and this is the bad part
about being a non-profit because like I
have a non-profit at home with my mom
not animal rescue farm and she had the
same thing happen where people that were
on the board tried to overthrow and take
it over so when you have people that are
really involved in their own
ulterior motives they can literally vote
you out of your own thing that you
started from the ground up and that's
what James did and I just think it's
really disgusting and it will backfire
on them because I've only seen
outstanding and unrelentless or
unrelenting support online all Candice
Owens is tweeting that her money people
are saying their money is going to
follow James and it will only backfire
so it's just it's crazy I think this is
the most interesting dramatic right-wing
drama that's going on right now and it's
really upsetting to me what this letter
is saying I think you're absolutely
right I mean it shows how much the
donors believe James will keep but more
than that that when they're fundraising
James O'Keefe's is an integral part of
what they're giving to and so what
they're asking is that they honor donor
intent which a lot of Courts recognize
as an obligatory condition for uh giving
a non-profit money and that it's not
surprising to me that people are saying
it's essentially a non-profit version of
false advertising like if James walks
then this is not what I would have given
my money to which is a very strong
message to send right I wonder what
they're thinking I wonder what the rain
leaders are thinking right now because I
can't I can't imagine that they're
looking at the response and thinking oh
this is going well and what did they
think was going to happen do like people
love James O'Keefe I think and this is I
have no idea if a product career test
but some organizations uh you can
effectively donate enough to be given a
seat on the board right and so there
could have been people who thought yes I
like what this is doing but I want to
have more influence over it and
eventually we're asked to join the board
maybe because they had high capacity and
were able to really financially support
the mission and that doesn't have to be
a bad thing if the person who comes onto
the board has honorable intentions right
right but for other people it's a quick
it's a it's a foot in the door to have a
paragraph and we just don't know what
this was what's a language
name a language any language other than
English French French
all right I have an idea for for James
O'Keefe let me just uh I probably should
know how to say this but um it's a
vetate so uh it's probably too close he
can't use the French it's romantic so
it's too similar
Afrikaans how do you say truth in
Afrikaans uh it depends on how you say
it I mean truth yeah trying to think
about I've never had to say that before
I speak I speak like farmers of Recon so
I don't know yeah Farmers okay uh
Japanese Warhead
I like it
how about Arabic
I can't read that it's a terrific how do
you read it I looked and it's like I
can't read Arabic I can't read it do you
read polish uh oh yeah polish would be
good or Russian and German German always
sounds mean Chinese
he wrote that book called American
Pravda just makes it profitable I mean
actually he could do project profit
I think that those are both terrible
you're such a hater Phil you know you're
such a rhino let me just be here to go
ahead jumping on the parade shinjitsu is
that really how you say truth is that a
dog breed shitsu shinjitsu
um in regard to this project Veritas
so I mean there there's a long list I
think of legitimate criticisms that you
could weigh towards James O'Keefe
however I think project Veritas did not
do a good job making any of those
arguments uh and I think there seems to
be people on the board who got extremely
arrogant because
project Veritas literally is James
O'Keefe just like how Tim cast literally
is Tim Poole I I just don't understand
what they were thinking because any way
you view project Veritas James O'Keefe
really is the face like he completely
represents the organization and I just
think somebody's overstepping got very
arrogant thought very highly of
themselves I'm sure James O'Keefe could
be a tough boss I've interviewed James
before he could be a little bit
hard-headed he could be a little bit
heated at times some people question his
journalistic methods but that's not
really like I think this isn't a force
out this is why you know one of the most
important things we can do is is get rid
of these labor laws I mean if a boss
wants to flog as employees because
they're not doing their jobs well James
O'Keefe has that right yeah quit I love
working on Tim Cass it's so fun that's
great the the the beatings will continue
until morale approves right uh no I
think it's money I think that um some
people pointed out one of the board
members has like he him or whatever in
his profile or something yeah he was
fired I guess a few months ago and then
brought back from what I was reading and
I don't know red flag with the he him
and his bio but that's weird right but I
I my view is I'm biased and so I'm not
saying I have any evidence to suggest
this is true I'm just saying in my
personal opinion based on having worked
in nonprofits they have like a ton of
money okay like donors gave a lot of
money to Veritas you're not going to be
able to touch it with James O'Keefe
standing guard over it like as the
ideological founder of the operation
he's going to spend that money on what
he thinks how it's got to be done of
course the board members will have a
certain degree of say
but they're not going to increase
salaries they're not going to pay like I
don't know if the board members can take
a salary but you're not going to have
discretionary spending of this with an
ideological founder you oust him you
find a way to get rid of him all of a
sudden you can then put whoever you want
in charge who can control that all that
money
there's a big paycheck said it's you
know right right there with James
O'Keefe in the way yeah I feel bad that
there they put out the other day with
that guy Joe or whatever his name was I
feel bad for him but I gotta be honest
that dude should never have done that
video you saw it yeah I saw it from you
guys showed on last night's episode
right yeah he shouldn't have done it
because it looks like he's part of the
ringleader thing or the cool the cool
looks like he's part of it even though I
don't know if he is or not to be honest
it's a cool man
do you think he would do it because he's
like afraid if he thinks they really
have the power to oust James and I I
have no idea the guy in the video yeah I
mean if you thought your job was
refreshing if you threatened you really
believed in your mission and you really
thought the board was gonna pull off
whatever they're trying to pull off
would you feel obligated to do the
things they asked um I my personal
opinion is anyone who saw any employee
that signed that like letter of
Grievances and is at all siding with the
board members that are trying the
ringleaders trying to outs James O'Keefe
our scum of the earth I don't care
that's if you're around James o'keeba he
might be a tough boss he's never been my
boss but you know that his heart and
soul is in this Mission and if you're
either dumb or there's malice to it
that's how I feel worry the official
complaints it was about him being yes uh
yeah he's a micromanager that he was
um an egomaniac at times that he was a
bully something about sand and
Underpants egomaniac is every CEO
micromanaging happens at every company
too so that's why those are just
ridiculous first it's not like there are
legitimate reasons or things that people
could do to warrants getting kicked out
of a company but just the things that
they listed sounded so yeah they're
saying his behavior is erratic and they
were asking that the board intercede and
basically take management away from him
and also internally from what I
understand uh they shared a message to
their staff saying he's uh James is just
taking some well-deserved PTO and then
later had to say actually he's he's been
separated has O'Keefe come out and
responded nothing yet I think there's
more to oh okay interesting yeah well I
mean look he's probably got contracts
ndas Etc I reached out to him he never
got back to me I don't blame him they
put him on leave and then what's he
gonna do be like you know violate a
contract or something it does surprise
me that they put out a statement but
he's not allowed to put out a statement
that's normal is it normal I mean yeah
if a company has an NDA with you they
can enforce it against you but they can
say whatever they want
yeah I mean that's a reality also it
seems to me
not a bad idea to just keep everything
close to the chest I mean it's James
O'Keefe who knows what he's planning
what were they thinking about this
that's what I think another thing one of
the Grievances I found funny that people
were complaining about was that he made
employees take a lie detector test and I
was like that makes me love James even
more trust no one which is these people
that are trying to overthrow him have
proven to him and also he wants to make
sure that he's actually having the most
most truth truthful journalism coming
out like you don't trust anyone I love
that he's second guessing everyone's
like just take a lie detector test but
that's like your worst criticism of him
he's trying to expose the truth in my
opinion and these people are just
looking for anything anything that just
take him down you saw in the letter it
said some of these people never
witnessed or experienced any race then
why sign a letter and all of the that's
why they're dumb or evil in my view the
timing here is so insane saying too
because the Pfizer videos the like the
different parts of them I saw one got
over 15 million views so like this is a
you know they're still very influential
they're still very powerful and like on
the heels of that is when they choose um
to remove him or put him on paid leave
and maybe I mean this is being
conspiratorial this is just me
speculating I'm not even saying that I
actually think this is what is happening
but it could be a possibility that
someone like if Pfizer of these big
companies are paying out paying these
people ring leaders to overthrow James
O'Keefe because they realize that
project Veritas is nothing with James
O'Keefe so maybe because I actually
think that maybe they're money driven to
try to overthrow him but at the same
time the money's gonna be cut off maybe
they didn't predict that but it seems
like it would be cut off but maybe
there's outside influences trying to
because you know people are trying to
take down James O'Keefe and project
Veritas thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time